[Music]
we're on the ground in Vegas tonight
where fifty nine people have died 527
literally were injured 527 people
innocent civilians Americans that of
course after a madman went on a rampage
during a Country Music Festival
so tonight authorities they're still
working to determine the motive behind
this shooting but here's what we know so
far about this madman his name is Steven
paddock according to his brother he was
a multi-millionaire who was a frequent
gambler there are also reports that the
gunman's father was a convicted bank
robber once had been on the FBI's ten
most wanted list and according to
authorities Patek extensively planned
this massacre
there's also newly released video of the
hotel room crime scene where you can see
the guns that paddock used to carry out
this deadly attack laying on the ground
and according to police 23 guns were
found in the room including some that
were modified in order to fire like an
automatic weapon and according to
reports padic he set up a camera inside
the hotel room to actually film his
rampage he also by the way set up
security footage and we're asking the
hotel tonight release this the American
people deserve to see what happened
police also saying the paddock put a
camera inside of a food cart that was
left outside of his room in the hallway
so he could see if any police were
coming and also tonight we're learning
more about the shooters girlfriend her
name Mary Lou Dan Lee who authorities
are now saying is a person of interest
sources are telling Fox News the paddock
sent thousands of dollars overseas that
may have been for his girlfriend as she
is currently traveling in the
Philippines however it remains unclear
who actually received this money and US
government sources were telling Fox News
that investigators have interviewed an
immediate relative of Steven paddocks
girlfriend this relative described the
gunman as quote unstable and said he
made them feel very uncomfortable we'll
have much more on the possible motive
all throughout this hour tonight but
first Democrats liberals in the
mainstream media celebrities late-night
comedians all predictably rushing to
politicize this tragedy and
addictively calling for more gun control
and we're going to get to those examples
in a second but unlike them we have
promised you on this show
we care about truth we care about facts
we care about victims and families and
we're not peddling conspiracy theories
or rushing to judgment we're not trying
to use this incident to score cheap
political points now it's probably why
we almost doubled our competitors in the
ratings last night the American people
you can no longer trust these people in
the mainstream media it is sad
journalism in America's debt now
yesterday we told you for example
liberal CNN reporter Jeff Zeleny he said
the only reason the president Trump
cares about the Vegas shooting
is because the victims were probably his
supporters we also told you about CBS
having to fire one of their lawyers why
for mocking the shooting victims and not
even caring well tonight unfortunately
things are getting much worse now before
we show you these grotesque and
appalling examples I want you to watch
this ever so powerful video this is from
the concert last night about an hour
before the shooting took place almost
30,000 people in that crowd my friends
Big and Rich led the crowd honored the
military all almost everyone in the
crowd raising their phone with their
light and singing collectively god Bless
America watch this powerful video
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so powerful so necessary we all need to
come together like the people in that
crowd did one hour before that master
they weren't Republicans and Democrats
liberals and conservatives Americans
singing god Bless America we were
explaining you know this is what exactly
is happening and as we get more details
we'll bring it to you in the beginning
my monologue I just played as we were
going to break how one hour before this
all took place Big and Rich we're on
stage and they had everybody in the
crowd almost 30,000 people holding up
their cell phones and light in unison
singing god Bless America but yet you
saw within literally hours the left
politicizing this event before any facts
were known let me start with the
late-night comedians for example they
were lining up literally at the chance
to exploit this incident for political
purposes when what they should have been
doing is what we played you earlier in
the program watch this Congress can be
heroes by doing literally anything
universal background checks or come up
with a better answer enforced Obama's
executive order that denied mentally ill
gun purchases or a better answer
reinstate the assault weapons ban or
come up with a better answer anything
but nothing doing nothing is cowardice
when someone with a beard attacks us we
tap phones we invoke travel bans we
build walls we take every possible
precaution to make sure it doesn't
happen again but when an American buys a
gun and kills other Americans then
there's nothing we can do about that and
second amendment I guess our forefathers
wanted us to have a k47 we seemed to do
everything to avoid talking about guns
I've never been to a country where
people are as afraid to speak about guns
how does every other developed country
do a better job of preventing these
attacks we can't be surprised that gun
crime will always occur where there is
such wide availability of guns to
Congress I would just like to say are
there no steps we can take as a nation
to prevent gun
this is beyond shameful making political
statements calling for things like gun
control less than 24 hours after
something like this happens while people
are grieving while victims are still in
the hospital before we have any and all
facts it is utterly disgraceful mothers
and fathers in hospitals hoping and
praying their children or literally
fighting for their lives are going to be
okay
really late-night host she can't resist
the urge for one night put aside your
radical left-wing policies and by the
way you're often so wrong about the
issue it's sad then you have celebrities
taken to Twitter they make their cheap
political points Lena Dunham for example
oh no way not to politicize this tragedy
it's about gender and race as well as
access to guns considering its random is
comforting and dangerous Lady gaga all
of the great political philosopher she
is she writes prayers are important but
Paul Ryan and real Donald Trump blood is
on the hands of those who have power to
legislate and she writes hashtag gun
control act
hey Lady gaga where were you when all
the violence in Chicago was happening
Gigi Hadid it sickens me the ease with
which a terrorist can be sold a gun it's
the ease all these lives this needs to
stop work Sophia Bush tweeting dear
Donald fu for this truly sincerely
America Alyssa Milano tweeting doesn't
our children's safety mean more than
your right to own weapons that can kill
on a mass scale fu an RA now here's the
hypocrisy celebrities are completely out
of touch now shouldn't they be focused
now they're also carrying on victims and
their families instead of trying to
score cheap political points against the
president and advancing their left-wing
ideology by the way here's the hypocrisy
they want to disarm all of us all of you
the American people prevent you from
having the right to protect yourself
protect your family how many of them
live in expensive multimillion-dollar
gated communities how many of them have
armed security any time they leave their
house so the attacks from these
celebrity shouldn't surprise anybody
look what's Saturday Night Live this
weekend said about President Trump take
a look at this
oh really Donald you [ __ ]
this isn't that complicated man is
hurricane relief these people need help
you just did this for white people twice
do the same thing go tell Melania to put
on her flood heels get some bottled
water some food pack up some extra
Atlanta Falcons Super Bowl t-shirts and
write them a check with our money you
cheap crack up really you have to wonder
would they ever say that about Barack
and Michelle here's Hillary Clinton also
lashing out in her effort to exploit
what happened watch her this is nothing
but pure unadulterated greed motivated
by people who want to sell as many guns
as they can to engage in a falsity of
fear and rhetoric about why everybody
has to have guns and you know there's
just the evidence is just so clear that
more guns do not keep you safer no read
John lot more guns less crime she waited
a whopping nine hours before she started
playing politics with what happened here
she's just bitter and angry and frankly
disgraced X presidential candidate
beyond disgraceful other Democrats
they're also following this example so
predictable watch this
I know these are harsh words but I
believe it in my heart I think there is
an unintentional endorsement that gets
sent to these mass murders when after
slaughter after slaughter Congress does
nothing in the face of tens of thousands
of gun deaths every year too many
Republicans in Congress have tried to
enact the dream agenda of the NRA and
the gun lobby evil attacked Las Vegas
but we can do something about it we can
say enough is enough we're saying enough
to the evasion and the euphemisms they
can take those euphemisms and stuff them
and I think we have to ask ourselves the
same question again is there nothing
that we can do no law nothing that we
can do want to know what pathetic looks
like look at these tweets a democratic
elected congressman is named Seth
Moulton as after Orlando I will not be
joining my colleagues in a moment of
silence on the House floor that just
becomes an excuse for inaction now is
not a moment of silence it's a time for
action
really congressman you're that petty
you're that bitterly partisan you can't
even bow your head and honor those that
died and those that are fighting for
their lives and hospitals you are
pathetic and he wasn't alone Democratic
congresswoman Katherine Clarke also
refusing to honor victims with a simple
moment of silence these liberals these
people on the Left are so blinded by
their hatred of the president the Second
Amendment anyone conservative they can't
even focus on what is important and just
like celebrities these Democratic
politicians are massive hypocrites when
it comes to guns right don't they have
their own armed police force just to
keep them safe most Americans don't have
that and like a lot of celebrities and
all these late night hosts that have
paid their millions of dollars you want
to have a debate that's fine facts
aren't on your side let's take a look at
this headline John Lott jr. gun control
in Europe is almost total it hasn't
stopped mass shooting attacks like Las
Vegas and then lot points out that
Europe has some of the strictest gun
control laws on the planet yet there are
still mass shootings there and by the
way the left are always morally outraged
over these mass shootings but to even
remember them talking about the out of
control violence unprecedented violence
in Chicago when Barack Obama was
president let's look at the videotape
statistics here during the Obama
presidency there were over 3,900 murders
in his adopted hometown did you hear
anything from the left the late-night
comedians Lady gaga the genius that she
is or what about the more than 18,000
people shot in Chicago just during the
last 6 years of Obama
his presidency did anybody on the left
all these people out there did any of
them go to Chicago to try and help those
people being shot we listed their names
on this show take a look at the side of
your screen will show you the victims of
this shooting here in Vegas throughout
the hour this is the only thing that
matters right now honoring those
Victor's victims supporting their
families praying for their recovery that
should be the main focus of the moment
now's not the time to make cheap
political points to bide the country
push your cheap political agenda and try
and use the tragedy to further a bitter
partisan agenda how about the country
can come together like they did an hour
before this terrible shooting and nearly
30,000 people with their cell phones in
the air and their lights bright as the
light can see you know singing god bless
america